only 12 of the world  are natural executors only 12 of the  world  and i looked at the numbers like yo  that's kind of crazy but i get it they  so demanding that if it was 50 of them  it would it would be crazy  if you had to deal with that personality  it would be a lot to have to deal with  50 of the world is that  right so less than 12 of the world are  executed naturally  so what happens is they come in a room  and they're not trying to be you know  negative but they sell you the stuff  they tell you to do this stuff and they  it's naturally in them and then you go  home like why can't i do it because  they're not they're not thinking about  you and who you are as a person